[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
so langsam wird es zur tradition dass
ich nach gemacht wie das mache aber ihr
habt euch wirklich ganz viele davon
gewünscht unter anderem auch die
backmischung von dr oetker die schoko
sahne schnitte
also werde die zeit zu bereiten einmal
das original und dann natürlich auch
noch meine eigene version
und dann mache ich noch eine dritte
version ich werde diesen kuchen nämlich
auch noch vegan zu bereiten damit unsere
zwei veganer volkan und dennis auch was
zu essen haben also heute gibt es gleich
drei varianten und zwar ist hier im
innern also ich habe es noch nie
ausprobiert aber hier ist ein
schokokuchen darüber eine schoko creme
und die backmischung hat sogar eine
eigene backformen aus papier
die muss man sich einmal kurz zusammen
falten aber das mache ich dann später
wenn ich diese version mache ich habe
jetzt hier mir einen tag ausgesucht denn
ich auf meinen basics habe einen
schokokuchen mit eiern sahne und öl
wirklich ganz einfach und ich mache es
dann einfach immer so
ich sehe hier schon ungefähr die menge
wie viel backmischung ich habe was ich
noch zu fügen muss und dann kann ich
ungefähr auch selber einfach abschätzen
wie viel zeit ich herstelle für meinen
teil verwende ich zwei eier eine prise
salz 100 gramm zucker etwas vanille
extrakt jeweils 100 gramm sonnenblumenöl
und sahne 125 gramm mehl einen teelöffel
backpulver und 25 gramm cacau ok jetzt
geht es im prinzip direkt los nehme
jetzt zuerst die eier die kommen in der
rührschüssel dann zucker und salz und
vanille extrakt ich glaube bei der
backmischung ist wieder so ein all-in
teig also einfach alles verrühren
hierauf drei minuten drei millionen auf
höchster stufe
egal wenn man uns vorher so ich
verrühren die eier etwas schaurig
so wird der kuchen schön luftig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt die eier zuckermasse schön cremig
und ich kann die beiden flüssigkeiten
dazugeben sahne und öl kurz einrühren
und hier habe ich jetzt schon die
trockenen zutaten vermischt also mehl
backpulver und cacau
die werden noch kurz dazu gesiebt und
dann wirklich nur kurz einrühren
bis sich alles schön verbunden hat
[Musik]
perfekt und jetzt nehme ich einfach
meinen back rahmen die kleinste
einstellung des und 20 x 25 cm
ich denke das kommt jetzt ganz gut hin
so mit der größe für den tag hinein und
kann ihn dann direkt packen und in der
zwischenzeit zeige ich euch schon mal
die zutaten für den veganen kurz
[Musik]
für den weg gab es schokokuchen brauche
ich 20 gramm leinsamen die sind ganz 70
gramm wasser 100 gramm veganer butter
oder margarine etwas vanille extrakt 100
g zucker mit prise salz 125 gramm mehl
drei viertel teelöffel backpulver und 25
gramm cacau wäre ja das war ich mal
nicht dass ich nichts zu tun aber ich
habe gerade einen kuchen
okay ich mache ich noch die vegane
version und wenn du magst du kurzzeitig
trend stark machen
das schaffst du es nur zwei eier und
milch ich werde noch in diesem jahr
saniert aber guck mal was jetzt zuerst
mache ich erkläre ich mal kurz was ich
jetzt beim veganen tag anders machen und
zwar nehme ich jetzt hier kein öl
sondern vegane butter also margarine aus
wir haben auch veganer butter genommen
oder vegane marina kraus aus
schleswig-holstein unglaublich schleswig
holstein aus schleswig holstein wird
genau veganen butter ausgehen und sogar
mich ganz lieben gruß amt nach
schleswig-holstein naja und ein ersatz
ist bei mir jetzt bei mir die leinsamen
denn die haben viel eiweiß protein und
haben einfach eine tolle binder
eigenschaft nimmt er aber ganz allein
samen und rote die das heißt zerkleinert
sie es gibt ja auch schon geschrotete
leinsamen aber die könnt ihr nicht
nehmen den bei geschrotetem leinsamen
wird das fett entzogen und im prinzip
alles was wir jetzt brauchen
und da habt ihr einfach diese binde
eigenschaften nicht mehr als ist schon
wichtig die jetzt wirklich selber zu
schrooten
gaßner drei sekunden sagt es wirklich
nicht weiß wo man als veganer ohne das
ding jetzt auskommen könnte den moerser
vielleicht denke ich wird auch gegen
kopfweh garten börse daheim in
sicherheit
hauptsache schön find roten ihr seht
doch das ist wirklich ganz feines pulver
geworden und ich sag dir vielleicht
warum geschrotete leinsamen worten denen
alles entzogen wird denn so würden die
an sich werden durch das ganze fest
und deswegen wird ihnen das leinöl
entzogen
ok hier gebe ich jetzt wasser dazu und
jetzt muss es einfach kurz quellen so
etwa eine viertelstunde
das heißt ich lasse meine zutaten stehen
und murat du darfst gerne die partie
schon in der halle voll begeisterung
hören ist alles weiß mit dem grantig
werden unter anderem daran dass kommt
man lieber mehrere
für die ganz normalen menschen ich mache
mache ich so was kann daran schon schwer
sein
hier steht muss erstmal die anleihe die
backformen falten machst du bist der
backform 8 grad
achten sie mal cool back form nach
anleitung auf der backform aufstellen
debug form nach anleitung auf der
backform aufstellen
auch ein backhaus krass da sind die
backform zum dialog mit ihnen alles
gedacht
jetzt habe ich die backform schon
festlegen muss ich sagen so und ich hab
dir das ist schon vorbereitet mischung
für den boden in eine schüssel geben 100
gramm schlagsahne und einzufügen mit
einem mixer früher stellte war die
bresche
er hat mir schon in den burschen eine
heiße mischung
ich hab mir mal alle drei sind mal
heraus was die backmischung ist
backmischung steht drauf und zwar auch
auf allen sprachen mischung da reingeben
so sieht's aus quatsch das ist auch
schoko stücke drin hat es gesehen rechts
hatten leider vereinigten schritt auch
richtig cool es riecht nach moustafa war
und dann heißt einfach die sah nämlich
rein
so soll die sahne mit rein und zwei eier
doch ok und dann auf niedrigster stufe
drei minuten rühren nein zuerst auf
niedriger stufe und dann drei minuten
nach fester stoffe ok niedrigste stufe
genau hat er es das ist eine homogene
masse gibt und alle ingredients zusammen
verbunden haben genau so und jetzt drei
minuten ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
berlin
immer noch
[Applaus]
stopp
die längsten drei minuten wegen so jetzt
nehmen wir die dinger raus
hier drücken naja spielt auch die kaaba
gar nicht ganz ganz einfach
castro war mir einfach das eigentlich
jetzt nehme ich das ding gut machst
einfach da rein so was ist rechtskräftig
auch gerade noch so geschafft haben wir
darüber gar nicht so einfach ne nähe ist
nicht einfach aber ich muss eins sagen
weil das ideal ist das ist jetzt keine
produktplatzierung seien aus und silikon
löffel das ist alles richtig schön sex
aber wir sind aber meine entschuldigung
haben nennen wir ihn mal finde ich echt
der wahnsinn ja so murat ich bin kein
mensch der so komplizierten schlüssel
aus graz von cramm gekriegt private
wahrscheinlich heißt ja gott sei dank
auch jeden genau hat es gesehen
es macht wenn man's richtig macht hat
man sogar noch die restlichen 20 prozent
raus genau seit fast genau so lange
gebraucht wie mein kuchen
ich muss sagen jetzt zum ersten mal habe
ich machen so heiß nachdem uhr alex
gemacht eigentlich ist voll voll einfach
so eine backmischung mich nachdem ich
jetzt gut verteilt super hervorragend da
david ich mache noch einmal so ist auch
ganz ganz wichtig und zwar einmal noch
so ein sieg macht man etwas schlechter
luft rein und jetzt schlägst du daraus
machst du auch schon mal gemacht werden
muss ja was dann wenn man die luft raus
muss aber du hast ja jetzt drei minuten
lang luft eingeschlagen steige das bitte
raus dass sie das sieht dann richtig
intelligent aus
ok auf jeden fall land habe ich hier
noch zwei andere packungen muss erst mal
packen war sie komme ich mache also ein
kuchen ist fertig der offizier das war
es einfach und natürlich also mit dem
blecher diese papierform indes in den
backofen
also ich würde sagen der brauch maximum
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie die backform
reagiert aber eigentlich maximum 20 ok
30 kommt heute backen passt dann braucht
man etlichen brodeln und dann steckt in
europa backofen oder wie es die
österreicher sagen
makro mieterin 6 kurz machen perfekt ich
mache mal 20 mal gucken wir einfach mehr
krieg sie okay also schaut euch jetzt
mal hier die leinsamen ankommt wo sie
jetzt so richtig zurecht findet
du merkst so richtig wie kleister im
prinzip nur riechen nicht ins gericht
geht es riecht ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber später im
kuchen genau das jedoch wenig leicht aus
aber später im kuchen wird es so lustig
es wird dann echt ist echt schlecht ich
hatte auch schon mal mit galileo hatte
ich ja schon mal ein beitrag gemacht wie
man ersetzen kann und da habe ich das
auch macht und jetzt nämlich einfach
vegane butter aus schleswig holstein
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe es nicht
auf die zutaten geguckt aber ich finde
ich mein ich würde gerne öfter vegan
backen aber ich muss sagen ich verzichte
ich gerne auf soja und da momentan alle
sahne und butter und milchprodukte auf
soja basis sind es schon für mich so ein
bisschen ja nicht ganz so ideal
vielleicht gibt es ja was besseres ihr
könnt ja in die kommentare schreiben
ok dann wandel extrakt dazu jetzt auch
vegan zucker und salz und jetzt wie
vorhin einfach schön cremig verrühren
machst du das machen
[Applaus]
dann ist das aber wirklich die butter
mit dem zucker schön schaut wird denn
ich brauche jetzt hier auch dieses
volumen diese cremigkeit und daher
verzichte ich jetzt hier auf öl und
neben des lebens wie brutal ausschließen
holstein entweder nimmt man eier zum
zerstören oder ihre mutter
ausschließlich wohlstand und da ist ja
in welcher zeit gebuttert ausschließlich
als
ich bin öfter für seine mitarbeit
bitte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich muss mich übrigens korrigieren
kein soja palmfett gut kokosöl wasser
karottensaft konzentrat zitronensaft
konzentrat und zitronenöl nur eins sagen
aus kontrolliert biologischem anbau ist
gefallen
[Applaus]
und da kommen jetzt die leinsamen dazu
macht mich höher
[Applaus]
mein gott im schnitt rechte arm ein
das alles nicht
macht das haus nicht nach machte zu
hause sind nach was sie heißen am rand
aber wand gespritzt
[Applaus]
der schön noch sechseinhalb minuten noch
sechs monaten ja und jetzt einfach hier
die trockenen zutaten dazu 7
wenn die masse gleich zu fest wird
einfach denn mandelmilch dazu geben oder
hafer milch ein schöner cremiger
rührteig aber ich gebe es hier noch
diesen wandel milch dazu damit er
einfach auch ein bisschen flüssiger wird
[Musik]
perfekt probieren ja wissen zwar kann
das schlecht gab es fast noch besser als
ich gut weil das semi gestrigen jetzt
auch eine einführung in die backform im
ofen backen und sobald alle drei kuchen
abgekühlt sind geht es gleich weiter
[Musik]
für meinen original kuchen verwende ich
300 gramm sahne und 150 gramm zarter
schokolade für den veganen natürlich 300
gramm vegane sahne und 150 gramm peter
kuvertüre die ist nämlich auch vegan und
moral sind alle zutaten
ich verwende sahne und backmischungen
also du kannst einfach zubereiten aber
vielleicht mache ich ganz kurz vorher
vegane schokolade ist einfach bitter
kuvertüre da ist nämlich kein milchbauer
vertritt das heißt die könnt ihr
verwenden
und ich nehme jetzt einfach nur die zwei
zutaten und später noch seiner partner
zu und so speichern jetzt einfach
puderzucker den salat ist auch leicht
gesüßt und da passt das ganz gut
ich werde jetzt nur folgendes machen ich
habe ein arbeitsschritt mehr ich nehme
jetzt 100 gramm sahne koch sie auf und
ließ sie dann über die schokolade damit
sie schmilzt und lasst dann kurz im
kühlschrank wieder kalt werden und du
kannst im prinzip gleich loslegen
[Applaus]
und sobald die sahne kocht einfach den
herausstellen
die schokolade zu geben und so lange
rühren bis geschmolzen ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und ich fühle jetzt diese leckere
schokolade einfach schon mal in die
rührschüssel stellst kurz in den
kühlschrank und kann dann danach eben
die show samt hatte ich mache jetzt bist
du dran wo hat die vegane bereinigt
übrigens genauso zu den ausgewaschenen
topf ja vor allem hast du schon ganz
einfach eine kollision bezieht die kalte
sahne und die saar ein nachdenken da
rein gemacht habt macht ihr einfach auf
und stellt die mischung mit rein
wir warten zu unterhalten oder pulli sie
dann hier den den rühe starb den magic
stick und und machten erst mal an war
der niedrigste stufe anfangs man muss
immer erst dann okay das ist ja so jetzt
schneller machen und nicht durchdacht
genug geld weg
[Musik]
also woran merkt man dass die sahne
steif ist die ist jetzt noch zu flüssig
der tipp geben und auch ansturm der fans
schon lange sind menschen die sich gerne
wie sie diese sahnehäubchen darauf
stehen bleiben
dann überlegten langsam machen wir jetzt
nicht so fasst fast fertig sie es lust
noch einen dicken bock und nach dem
titel kosten
lieber so politisch hat hat nicht
installiert neben ihr stehen das ist
halt siehst du siehst dann habe ich ja
gesagt strom dieser steht ja genau jetzt
nicht denn über kopf teste das geht und
jetzt müsst ihr folgendes beachten jetzt
hole ich nämlich den den kuchen
den habe ich auch genau aus dem
kühlschrank weil er habe ich im
kühlschrank und ganz wichtig hier wird
richtig fehler machen den kuchen heißt
raus so seien die sahne drauf machen ist
ein riesenfehler
und da heißt plötzlich habe sie
hingekriegt ist alles falsch das rezept
das abkühlen oh mein gott wer wird
bewusst dass du mir zu herzen
da waren sie überlegt murat vor zehn
jahren um murat heute das sind einfach
sein back talents wird immer mehr so
jetzt haben wir die drei punkte hier
wird es auch wohl locker leicht ist ja
so das ist jetzt und jetzt nehme ich
einen einen spatel genau genau dient als
schönheit und schwerst ganz drauf ich
kann dir eine palette geben denn ich
nehme später auch eine palette ab du
musst da nicht ganz glatt streichen
du kannst es ja auch so gewollt hier
sollte man also künstlerisch so ist es
kunst oder kann das weg
sieht doch so aus was soll ich da noch
die hülle zu lassen
die ecke hier voll verdenken und jetzt
kommt es im kühlschrank irgendwie eine
halbe stunde und 20 minuten
hier mache eine stunde eine stunde für
ungefähr eine stunde oder 20 minuten
auch ich freue mich auf meine top 2000
noch fertig und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder beim verkosten und beim
dekorieren weil die schokostreusel sind
auch hier drin sehr gut murat
[Musik]
hier ist übrigens die vegane schoko
sahne die kommt auch im kühlschrank habe
ich hier die kalte schoko sahne wirklich
darauf achten sie muss wieder
kühlschrank kalt sein
da kommt jetzt die übrige sahne dazu
trotz verrühren und dann einfach mit
seiner fahrt statt
[Musik]
die saale kommt jetzt hier auf den
kalten kuchen wie morath schon so schön
gesagt hat und dann mache ich gleich
noch die vegane sahne fertig ich mache
das jetzt auch so ein bisschen lockerer
wellig ist echt zum schneller
schokokuchen eine schöne schnelle
schnitte ab in den kühlschrank und
veganer schmettert kann
die vegane sahne die sieht schon cool
aus die ist nämlich echt so richtig
schneeweiß
da kann ich jetzt auch sommerbad
benutzen seiner fahrt ist nämlich auch
vegan und findet auch hier schön die
sahne steif schlagen
[Musik]
ich glaube vegane sahne hat den vorteil
dass man sie nicht überschlagen kann
sehr schöne konsistenz also ich würde
jetzt wenn ich jetzt den schokokuchen
gemacht hätte ohne dieses nachgemachte
ohne so hey ich mache die banken schon
nach hätte ich glaube ich den boden
schon noch ein bisschen getränkt mit
kaffee zum beispiel kaffee könnte nehmen
oder gern auch was anderes einfach damit
der boden noch saftiger wird wobei ich
glaube dass mein kuchen sehr saftig ist
noch als kuchen auch beim veganern weiß
ich nicht da gucken wir gleich das ist
nämlich nicht ganz so hoch aber es gibt
glaube ich trotzdem ganz gut aus
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das auch im kühlschrank dann
werden wir gleich die torten fertig
dekorieren wie man gespannt vereins
genauso schmecken also das ist der
vegane das sieht man an der hohen das
sieht richtig cool los jährlich ist ohne
spaß und jetzt kommt der dallas dann
wolken es heute nicht da allerdings
kommt komplett dem heer der wega ist
dennis beruf kommt ja okay was jetzt
auch noch kohle ist dass man auch gleich
habe ich das auch schon und zwar die hat
die die fit gemacht mischung finde ich
so tun hat eigentlich schokoladen
geschont und die kann ich jetzt richtig
cool verteilt das hat es nämlich und
vegane schokolade und weiße schokolade
eigentlich weiße schokolade ob
schokolade lernen ich glaube nicht ich
glaube auch nicht wegen kakaoanteil
genau weiß ich schon mal heißt mutter
ist bestimmt drin
ich sehe derzeit wo du ein gemacht das
habe ich zwei gemacht ja du musst du
doch einst bedenken dass die jetzt
abspülen muss und ich nicht mehr war es
positiv dass stimmt ein sehr süßes ich
mache das jetzt auseinander
außerdem sagt peter kummer theresa auch
vegan darf ich den gehabt keine chance
haben die nennt sich das torten retter
yamaha warum weil ich will das auch
schön aussieht
das ist unfair und bei mir nämlich noch
weiße kuvertüre dies jetzt nicht mehr
kann aber bei der normalen torte hier
achtung nicht das quiz kontaminiert mein
gott ist da nicht wusstest du dass bio
gemüse deswegen mit folie ummantelt ist
auch dass es mit konventionellen nicht
kontaminiert wird z der vorgang mache
ich will es gar nicht anpassen will ich
will nichts zerstören was sinn macht
heute ich muss mein leben schon so schön
hätte die torte auch nicht mehr so hier
weg von der veganen torte wirksamer hier
die wir gar nicht darauf zwischen den
beiden nicht länger abgespült
ich will jetzt auch rasseln der wir sind
so ich nehme noch us-dollar sony war
murat akyel der doch noch vegane raspel
schokolade ist haben wir auch noch ein
veganer hier ja schlimmer kann's jetzt
in der kommission anhand des optischen
tests kannst du jetzt sagen welcher
maßen okay wenn ihr egal welcher ist die
backmischung und welcher ist von mir ich
würde sagen das ist der veganer
warum will am stärksten riecht ja ich
sage immer wieder wenn es nicht besser
schmeckt muss es gesundheit ich spüre
einfach die verbindung zwischen dem
kuchen und mir und wir haben möchte gut
dann sagen wir jetzt der veganen welches
backmischung welcher ist nach gemacht
dass dort menschen wie lieb ich dich
geliebt wird geliebt ich dann also
faktisch und vegan nachgemacht ja
überhaupt so als ob man schneidet auch
erstmals einen veganen durch dafür zwar
zugeben ja und auch sagen die täten sie
immer mit verschiedenen messer damit es
nicht konnte mit genau das habe ich auch
gemacht habe alle materialien alles
nochmal die wahlergebnisse als ehrliches
frage zu plaques würde es ja dass
auswahl mit sally mit dem messer hier
der anderen partie als war jetzt schon
ein kuchen ist eine backmischung ein
kuchen ist veganer und einer ist nach
gemacht sagt mal optisch so was ist was
und wer wie viel schwieriger
wie viele geschwister hat jetzt harald
zusammengefallen noch die deswegen was
ist dann dessen was ist das komisch
gekauft er selber gemacht jetzt wisst
ihr warum war die bei uns arbeiten
wow schön luftig locker muss ich auch
sagen ganz ehrlich richtig locker aber
das ist auch egal
nein das werden nicht weniger also
dennis have fun party murat ihr könnt
euch durch probieren
also ich wo wir erst mal auch die partie
schon gut dass ich ihnen zehn minuten
früher aus dem ofen genommen habe 30 mal
ein stückchen hallo backzeit das ist das
ganze stück das ausprobieren
morath ganz ehrlich das ist das was die
letzten zwölf jahre schiefgelaufen ist
bei dem ich sage probier mal und den
ganzen kuchen auf 9 gold ihre mobilen
heißt ein stück also ich finde das ganz
cool muss ich sagen ja nur ich bin froh
dass ich hier nur 20 minuten gebacken
schmeckt doch super muss vulkan wolke
wohl kann der stern oben nein der
schotte weitergeht ist ja auch damit
erinnert diese zeit gar nicht so viel
zur veganerin ich finde das nicht hin
natürlich muss sein
er schmeckt ein bisschen süße aber ich
würde jetzt vielleicht sogar den hier
lieber ist immer ohne spaß das echt
ehrlich ohne spart richtig gut
der perfekt und damit der teig zu
trocken
das puzzle trocken geworden muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen also ich würde mein
weg geht ohne spaß
ich bin zwar vegan hayta aber ich würde
es in hessen wird nicht helfen ja ich
höre das mich essen also nicht die
hessen sondern essen
nico herzig muss sagen der konsistenz
ist die backen chance super ist gut der
ist schön saftig und aber nicht locker
der so kompakter aber so cremig in der
spießigen trocken geworden aber das habe
ich gesagt ich würde den kuchen
normalerweise tränken
also vegan super also ich finde sie
super probiert gerne aus und schreibt
uns welche der drei variationen er
gemacht habe
bis zum nächsten jahr und ihr könnt
gerne streiten ob ihr öfter mal sonne
sondern video sehen wollt normal und
vegan
doch immer noch schöne bilder
[Musik]